on this friday night from quebec city
the papal visit draws to a close
the pope's final brief stop in ocalaweed
where he's facing calls to bring a
priest to justice this monster cannot
cannot be allowed to get away for what
he did plus a desperate plea for
murdered and missing indigenous women i
feel like the pope is not touching on it
at all
canada's soccer accused of dropping the
ball many girls quit playing sports
because of this another blistering
report into sports and sexual misconduct
plus russia's astronomical ambition it
is 100 possible this is all just luster
the kremlin's planned to go it alone in
space
global national with farah nasser
reporting tonight from quebec city jeff
semple
pope francis touching down in ocala
tonight for the final stop in his
pilgrimage across canada the pontiff met
with residential school survivors from
nunavut and attended a public event and
celebration of inuit culture
good evening and thank you for joining
us we are coming to you again tonight
from quebec city where the pope began
this day he apologized again while
speaking to a small group of clergy
residential school survivors and
representatives from first nations in
eastern canada and tonight while
addressing the crowd in a calorie he
repeated that apology once again for the
historic wrongs carried out by in his
words more than a few catholics
a short while ago i listened to several
of you who were students of residential
schools yes yes
i thank you
for having had the courage
to tell your stories
and to share your great suffering
i had not imagined the suffering
this renewed in me the indignation
and the shame give me a companion that i
have felt for months
and you can see the crowd there the pope
addressing including residential school
survivors from some of nunavut's 13
residential schools the last one didn't
close until 1996 and it was an emotional
evening hard to find a dry eye in that
crowd the pope has made several
apologies over the course of his tour
here in canada but he is facing
criticism for not explicitly apologizing
for the institutional role of the church
in the residential schools our mike
armstrong has reaction from those who
gathered to hear the pontiff's message
here in quebec city this morning
there was some frustration as indigenous
leaders and survivors left the meeting
with the pope some of the support
workers escorting survivors were asked
to leave before it started the meeting
room as it turned out was too small for
everyone a lot of the room was reserved
for the bishops
i think in my view too many it was
exaggerated machine ensemble now what
came after that initial snag appears to
have been a success the pope in his
speech called this trip an intense
pilgrimage saying the stories he's heard
will stay with him and that he returns
home enriched i thought it was good
yeah he was very humbled and cheered
yeah i i noticed about him
following the pope's address the
survivors lined up and they addressed
the pope she was very
very receptive jones saint dennis says
she went up twice because the first time
she was flustered but her meeting she
says wasn't about anger i had a good
chuckle with him you know he said i
didn't go into any
anything about
the schools you know
i just told whatever
years that we went but they didn't get
into anything heavy
some of the leaders today said the
survivors who came represented many more
and that there is no right or wrong way
to react to this visit just as the pain
was an individual experience so is the
healing
if what the pope has shared hits home
for them that is their journey if there
are some survivors who do not
that's their journey
when noella robinson met the pope she
gave him a bottle of maple syrup she
joked it was to sweeten him up robinson
is today focusing she says on the
positive i am and that's what it's about
to me that's what it's about i'm an
older lady there now and i can't just
keep going back and rehashing the past
so today is closure and i will work
towards
good things and
hopefulness for our people
now one thing we heard over and over
today and in fact all week is that while
there are people like ms robinson there
are others who feel completely
differently the people who were here say
they know that and that that opinion has
to be respected people heal in different
ways and on different time tables jeff
mike armstrong here in quebec city
thanks mike
the canadian government has just issued
an extradition request calling on france
to send an oblate priest here to canada
johann rivoir is accused of sexually
abusing residential school students in
nunavut during the 1960s and 70s and
residential school survivors asked the
pope to intervene directly in that case
when they met with him in a callaweet
tonight
jack anawak has been waiting a lifetime
for this week
the 71 year old taking a boat trip near
his home in iqaluit with some of his
children and grandchildren while
reflecting on his own childhood anawak
was just nine when he was taken from his
home and forced to attend a residential
school in chesterfield inlet i was one
of those that was abused sexually
and i
it took about 30 years before
acknowledgment of that fact anna anawak
later became an mp parliamentary
secretary to the minister of indian and
northern affairs and an architect of
nunavut's first public government but
one of his proudest moments came in 1999
when he spoke out for the first time
about sexual abuse by catholic priests
there was quite a bit of opposition to
it but we persisted and persisted
and
the more we pushed it the more widely
known it became three decades later
anawak is now welcoming the pope to his
remote northern city
the pontiff greeted by residential
school survivors performing drum dancing
and throat singing a celebration of the
culture the church tried to destroy we
wanted to
stage that although there was an attempt
to take our language and our culture
away we have
strived to thrive at the ceremony this
survivor and her sister lit a colic oil
lamp in memory of their mother whom she
remembers standing on the shore watching
as her children were taken away by boat
she just stood there for the longest
time just staring away
and so i said
when when they started talking about
residential school and how hard it was
for themselves as children as it was
very hard on our mothers as well our new
fathers for the church's role in those
atrocities the pope was expected to
apologize in person but these survivors
say his actions moving forward will
speak louder they want one of their
alleged abusers a french priest named
johann rivwar to finally face justice
his actions were atrocious revoir worked
in many communities here in nunavut
during the 1960s and 1970s before
finally returning to france in the 90s
and a few years after that the rcmp
issued a warrant for his arrest revoir
was accused of sexually assaulting
several children in nunavut but france
refuses to extradite its citizens to
face charges abroad so the 93 year old
remains free reportedly living in a
retirement home for oblate priests this
monster cannot
cannot be allowed to get away for what
he did this former student planned to
raise rivars case with the pope directly
during their private meeting i'm sure he
has a lot of influence with the french
government we're heavily
leaning on pope francis to do something
about reborn to be brought back to
canada period the pope's visit to
iqaluit was scheduled to last just three
hours but these survivors were
determined to make every moment count
when the pope comes here and apologizes
in person and hopefully from the heart
i think there'll be a lot less skeptics
out there that these things really
happen there'll be that healing process
amongst not just us but our children
other people who were impacted by the
system
and so i think it will be a big step
forward for a lot of us
the federal government is accused of
failing to deliver on its pledge to end
violence against indigenous women and
girls and one advocate took those
concerns on the road this week hoping
for an assist from the holy father
neither garcia reports
lorelai williams whose indigenous name
is palehelsia packed carefully for her
trip from bc to alberta for the start of
the historic tour that's now in its
final leg i feel like the pope is not
touching on it at all
for more than a decade she's been
advocating for missing and murdered
indigenous women girls and two-spirit
people having lost her own aunt belinda
williams and her cousin tanya holik
whose dna was found on the farm of
serial killer robert picton she knows
first hand the systemic neglect that
fails them we get certain tips we go in
the community we're putting ourselves in
dangerous situations and i'm just like
why are the police doing this
you know it's so frustrating she's
fighting for the families of multiple
women around vancouver whose cases are
currently open i'm desperately searching
for tatiana harrison it's been more than
a year since ottawa released its
national action plan following the 2019
inquiry that concluded violence against
this demographic amounts to a genocide
in a news conference last month
advocates said little has been done this
is a national shame and it is also
dangerous
williams paid her own way to edmonton
and she did the same going to rome this
past spring when an indigenous
delegation met with the pope at the
vatican the genocide happened to our
people and it's still happening to our
people it would be really
nice
to
have him acknowledge the genocide that
has happened here
dina jules is a survivor of the former
kamloops indian residential school
before she left for edmonton to see the
pope's apology in person the community
elder said his acknowledgments and
actions are critical in creating
societal change we get a lot of hate
bill
and people that deny
that these atrocities happened if he
acknowledges it
if he supports us
some changes will be made and until then
she says she'll remain a visible and
outspoken symbol for her stolen sisters
nitu garcia global news
and a reminder that if you or someone
you know is a residential school
survivor and looking for help you can
call the residential school survivors
and family crisis line at 1-800-721-0066
turning to other news now and a damning
report that criticizes canada soccer for
mishandling sexual misconduct complaints
against a women's soccer coach now
you'll remember that hockey canada's
funding was frozen last month following
similar allegations but for now the
sports minister's office will only say
it is still analyzing the report on
soccer's governing body abigail beeman
has the details
i don't think i understood the damage
that
being silenced as we were for so many
years the toll it took keira mccormick
sounded the alarm years ago about her
former soccer coach bob berarda
now she's sickened to read the report
detailing how canada soccer mishandled
complaints but hopeful it brings change
it was just such a perfect storm in
terms of like all these
players with these big dreams and like
you know everything it meant everything
to play for the national team and then
that was literally what was weaponized
against us the report found a continuing
pattern of harassing emails sexting
flirting and other inappropriate
behavior from a coach with significant
power described as godlike verardo was
allowed to resign in 2008 the report
focused on a statement about a mutual
decision to part ways without mentioning
harassment calling it a gross
mischaracterization of the circumstances
and failed the victims of the harassment
their teammates and the organization as
a whole
with no oversight the organization did
not follow the procedures of their own
harassment policy the failure to
terminate berarda and impose
disciplinary sanctions afforded him the
opportunity to continue coaching putting
other players at potential risk
canada soccer did not respond to an
interview request saying in a statement
it accepts the findings and
recommendations and unequivocally
apologizes for letting participants down
these types of abuses and bullying are
widespread many girls quit playing
sports because of this before they have
an opportunity to really see what their
potential is many are hopeful the
spotlight on hockey canada will help
spur similar traction here i want to see
the same accountability soccer canada
hockey canada and other national sports
organizations need to be held to account
but also the ministry of sports and
sport canada needs to be held to account
perrarda currently awaits sentencing he
pleaded guilty to three counts of sexual
assault and one of touching a young
person for a sexual purpose his lawyer
did not want to comment on this new
review given the ongoing court action
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the supreme court of canada has ruled
that condom use can affect consent in
sexual assault cases the ruling is based
on a bc case in which a woman told a new
sexual partner that she would only have
sex with him if he wore a condom he did
the first time but not the second the
supreme court has ordered a new trial
for that case saying sex with a condom
is a fundamentally different act than
sex without one
and you are looking now at iqaluit the
final moments of the pope's trip here in
canada a farewell ceremony on the tarmac
before he flies back to rome and we'll
be right back
welcome back to quebec city dozens of
prisoners of war have been killed in a
missile strike in ukraine that both kiev
and moscow are blaming on each other
ukraine says russia targeted the prison
to hide the mistreatment of those being
detained there the ukrainian foreign
minister calling it a war crime but the
kremlin says ukraine is trying to frame
russian forces for the attack
ukraine meanwhile says the first grain
shipments are set to resume from its
port cities one week after a deal was
struck to allow their export through the
black sea in a rare trip outside of kiev
since the russian invasion the ukrainian
president visited a port today saying
he's awaiting the signal for the first
shipment
and at least 16 people including
children have been killed in flash
flooding in kentucky
the state's governor expects the number
of dead could double because the water
isn't expected to crest in some areas
until saturday entire communities are
under water some homes even floating
away emergency crews have already had to
make hundreds of rescues
spacing out still ahead russia's plan to
fly solo in space
well russia's war in ukraine drags on
the kremlin is also making moves in
space moscow wants to leave the
international space station and build
its own as resman shannon reports the
move spells the end of a decades-long
partnership between russia and the west
international cooperation in space goes
back long before the end of the cold war
in 1975 the soviet soyuz and american
apollo crews docked in space and met and
liftoff then for the past two decades
the international space station became a
permanent home to humanity from russia
and the west it's hard to overstate how
much they've truly trusted and relied on
each other this project the way it was
designed in the 90s
it was designed to be interdependent
because of the technological
architecture over the years seven
canadian astronauts have visited chris
hadfield even commanded it when russia
first invaded ukraine cosmonauts and
astronauts vowed to stay united but
since then russian crew members have
made patriotic gestures despite tensions
moscow and washington just signed a new
deal to continue flying to the station
but this week russia's new space agency
boss says he wants out
possibly as soon as 2024
nasa says moscow later clarified that it
will only leave once it finishes
building its own dedicated russian space
station we can be pretty sure that that
will take
at least five years
sanctions and war only make that even
more difficult for an increasingly
isolated russia in any case even the
americans want to mothball the aging iss
in the coming decade too it is 100
possible this is all just cluster
and they have every intention of
continuing their efforts with the
national space station and moscow is
unlikely to find a new partner in china
either both for technological and
political reasons the biggest benefit
for the national space station was that
it was a diplomatic tool
i don't know
what will replace it if and when russia
does leave our utopian ideal of
international cooperation could float
off into space redmond shannon global
news
london
up next reflecting on the pope's
pilgrimage of penance as his canadian
tour comes to a close we'll be right
back
welcome back to quebec city as the
pope's visit to canada comes to a close
residential school survivors and their
families are reflecting on an historic
week and the path forward
the road to reconciliation that saw the
pope journey from alberta to quebec to
nunavut in many ways began in kamloops
british columbia the discovery of more
than 200 potential unmarked graves near
a former residential school last year
that led to more discoveries across the
country and more shocking headlines but
those stories were old news to many
residential school survivors who'd been
demanding a pontiff apology for years
and then all of a sudden boom started
things started finally
things really started happening the
papal visit to canada is the first in
two decades the pope came to apologize
in person
[Applause]
i kind of felt very emotional about that
he said the right words that we want to
hear
but for many the pope's apology fell
short he blamed individual members but
not the church itself nor did he commit
to reparations or disclosing records or
returning indigenous artifacts or
revoking the 15th century doctrine of
discovery some are left asking where
reconciliation goes from here some
people say it's not enough i agree but i
think we have to start in a walk you
have to do the first step
even if not perfect
for many this week was an important step
on the path to reconciliation and
education canadians have been forced to
face a painful past that survivors hope
will shape their future
we have a flag that represents the
children who never returned home she
says it's a heavy burden to carry but
for many years we could never speak of
it today we can speak freely
and that is global national from quebec
city on this friday night i'm jeff
semple
[Music]
a celebration of inuit culture in
iqaluit in the final moments of the
pope's visit to canada he's now heading
back to the vatican marking the end of a
powerful and polarizing visit to this
country thanks for watching have a great
weekend
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]